ALAN ARCHULETA AT KANSAS STATE
BACKER FORGES BRADFORD COME BY
YELLOW CORTEZ THREE DALLY DODD
THERE. AIKMAN GLAZER GONZALES
GROVE HERZBERG WEST SO HER TADO
JONES CAN LONGER LAYERED LEYVA
LIMO OWN REQUIRE MELINDA'S MAN
NEWMAN NIELSEN A SHOW OF BOTH
HANDS FOURTEEN TINO RALPH RUBIO
SKINNER STERN NUMBERED BY CAL
SKI WINNER WELL. THANK YOU
MA'AM SECRETARY A QUORUM IS
PRESENT WITH THE MEMBERS AND
OUR GUESTS BEYOND THE RAIL AND
THE GALLERY PLEASE RISE. WE
WILL BE LED IN PRAYER THIS
MORNING BY SENATOR LEYVA. AFTER
WHICH PLEASE REMAIN STANDING
WILL BE LED IN THE PLEDGE OF
ALLEGIANCE TO THE FLAG BY
CENTER CHOKO CENTER LABOR.
THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT GOOD
MORNING MEMBERS LESSONS BY ROB
MCEWEN IN IMITATING CHRIST WE
MUSTN'T ONCE FORGET HIS CELL
THAT HE SELDOM WENT ALONE. HIS
FRIENDS OR THOSE WHO NEEDED
FRIENDS THEMSELVES. A TEACHER
HE WAS OFTEN TAUGHT AND NOT
JUST BY HIS FATHER BUT BY THE
FLOCK HE SHEPHERDED FROM
TORMENT INTO LOVE. HE WAS THE
WISEST OF HIS WISE MEN THAT
DIDN'T COME BY CHANCE IT CAME
FROM KAREN. GRACIOUS GOD WE
THANK YOU FOR CARING THAT YOU
HAVE A PLACE IN OUR HEARTS FOUR
BROTHERS AND SISTERS THANK YOU
FOR OUR FAMILIES AND FRIENDS
WHO GIVE US THE SPACE TO DO
YOUR WORK. AND WHO SUPPORT US
IN OUR JOYFUL AND DIFFICULT
DAYS AND HELP US TO BE GRATEFUL
FOR THE VOICES THAT CHALLENGE
US CHALLENGES TO GO DEEPER INTO
THE REASONS FOR THE
CONSEQUENCES OF OUR DECISIONS.
WE CONTINUE TO INCARNATE YOUR
VISION AND OUR WORLD A MAN.
MEMBERS PLEASE JOIN ME I PLAYED.
THANK YOU SENATORS. MESSAGES
FROM THE GOVERNOR WILL BE
DEEMED READ MESSAGES FROM THE
ASSEMBLY WILL BE DEEMED READ
REPORTS OF COMMITTEE WILL BE
DEEMED DREADED AMENDMENTS
ADOPTED MEMBERS WE'RE GONNA
MOVE TO MOTIONS RESOLUTIONS AND
NOTICES. DO WE HAVE MEMBERS
THAT NEED TO BE RECOGNIZED
UNDER MOTIONS. SENATOR BASE FOR
WHAT PURPOSE DO YOU RISE. UNDER
MOTIONS AND RESOLUTIONS MR
PRESIDENT AT THE REQUEST OF THE
AUTHOR PLEASE REMOVE AB
THIRTEEN OH FIVE FILE NUMBER
ONE OH TWO FROM THE CONSENT
CALENDAR FOR THE PURPOSE OF AN
IN MONTHS THANK YOU SENATOR
BATES SENATOR DOLLY. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR AT THE REQUEST THE
AUTHOR I'D LIKE TO REMOVE AV
EIGHT THIRTY ONE FROM THE
CONSENT CALENDAR. THE THANK YOU
SENATOR HOLLINGS DID YOU GET
THAT. THEY'RE JUST LIKE YOU SAY
ONE MORE TIME PLEASE EIGHT AV
EIGHT THREE ONE WOULD. THANK
YOU SIR VANS. THANK YOU MR
PRESIDENT UP PLEASE REMOVE FILE
ITEM NUMBER NINETY EIGHTY FIVE
THIRTY TWO BY SOME OF THE WOOD
FROM THE CONSENT CALENDAR AT
THE CREST OF THE AUTHOR FOR THE
PURPOSE OF MEN. THANK YOU THANK
YOU SENATOR PAN. THIS CENTER
TARA. THINK OUT OF. THANK YOU
MR PRESIDENT REQUESTED THE
AUTHOR RESPECTFULLY REQUEST A
FILE ITEM NUMBER NINETY NINE
EIGHTY NINE FOR SIMPLY REMOVED
FROM THE CONSENT CALENDAR TO BE
INACTIVE FILE. THANK YOU.
CENTRE HER TITLE ONE MORE TIME
PLEASE. AT THE REQUEST OF THE
AUTHOR I RESPECTFULLY REQUEST
THE FILE ITEM NUMBER NINETY
NINE EIGHTY NINE FOR SEVEN BE
REMOVED FROM THE CONSENT
CALENDAR TO BE AN ACTIVE FILE.
THANK YOU SENATOR. IN I'M BACK
I'M BACK. SENATOR HERTZBERG
PURPOSE DO YOU WRITE. THE INK
YOU HAVE TWO MOTIONS THE FIRST
IS AT THE REQUEST OF THE
AUTHOR. WE ASK THAT YOU PULL
THE FOLLOWING BILLS FROM THE
CONSENT CALENDAR FIRST. FILE AT
A NUMBER SEVENTY FOUR. WHICH IS
A. B. THREE FIVE ONE. SECOND
PULL FILE ITEM NUMBER NINETY
THREE. A. B. SIX EIGHTY NINE.
THANK YOU SECOND. OF MEMBERS I
MOVED THE ADOPTION THE SECOND
MOTION I MOVE. THE ADOPTION OF
THE AUTHOR'S AMENDMENTS FOR
MEASURES THAT CROSS THE DESK ON
FRIDAY SATURDAY AND SUNDAY.
JUNE TWENTY FIVE JUNE TWENTY
SIX IN JUNE TWENTY SEVEN TWO
THOUSAND ONE THESE AMENDMENTS
WILL BE ADOPTED PUBLISHED IN
THE MEASURES RETURN TO
COMMITTEE. THANK YOU SENATOR
HERTZBERG SERVERS MAKING A
MOTION TO ADOPT RESIDENT-
AMENDMENTS OVER THE WEEKEND
SENATOR WILK I THANK YOU MR
PRESIDENT- HIGH. RISE IN
OPPOSITION TO THE MOTION AND
EVERY YOU CAN RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR A ROLL CALL VOTE IS
COMPLETELY TEARS ASUNDER THE
WHOLE NOTION OF THAT SEVENTY
TWO HOUR RULE THAT THE VOTERS
ADOPTED WITH PROPOSITION FIFTY
FOUR WITH THAT I ASKED FOR A NO
VOTE. THANK YOU SIR WILL CENTER
HERTZBERG IS ASKING FOR AN HIGH
VOTE SENATOR WILK IS ASKING FOR
A NO VOTE SECRETARY PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. ALAN HI ARCHULETA I
ATKINS I BABIES. NO BACKER. HI
GORGEOUS NO BRADFORD FIVE BY
ADAM. CORTEZ THREE I DALLY. NO
DODD HI THERE ALSO I EXAMINE HI
BLAZER I CONSOLIDATE HIGH
GROWTH. NO HERTZBERG I WAS SO I
HER TADO. HI JONES NO KAMMERER
I LAYERED HI LLEVA HI THE MON.
MCGUIRE HI MELINDA'S NO MAN I
NEWMAN I NIELSEN. BUT SHOW UP
BOTH NO TAN FIVE FOURTEEN TINA.
I. ROSS HI RUBIO. HI SKINNER I
STERN I AM BERG ALL RIGHT I
LIKE HOW SKI I WINNER I WILL.
KNOW. HIGHS TWENTY NINE KNOWS
EIGHT MOTION PASSES. TAYING IN
MOTIONS AND RESOLUTIONS ARE
THERE ANY OTHER MEMBERS THAT
NEED TO BE RECOGNIZED UNDER
MOTIONS AND RESOLUTIONS SENATOR
SKINNER. THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT
MEMBERS I MOVED THE JOINT RULE
SIXTY TWO AA. BE WAIVED FOR THE
BUDGET IN FISCAL REVIEW
COMMITTEE TO MEET AGAIN HERE
ASSEMBLY BILLS ONE TWENTY NINE.
THROUGH ONE FIFTY NINE ON
MONDAY JUNE TWENTY EIGHT TWENTY
TWENTY ONE WITHOUT FOUR DAYS
NOTICE IN THE DAILY FILE. THANK
YOU SIR SKINNER SAYS SKINNER IS
MAKING A MOTION TO WAIVE RULE
SIXTY TWO AA SENATOR WILK. MR
PRESIDENT I AGAIN- RISE TO
REQUEST A ROLL CALL VOTE AND
ASK FOR A NO VOTE THIS IS UP TO
THIRTY BUDGET TRAILER BILLS.
BEING DONE OVER THE WEEKEND
WITHOUT THE PUBLIC TO HAVE A
PROPER OPPORTUNITY TO ENGAGE IN
THE PROCESS SO AGAIN I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR NOVEMBER.
THANK YOU THANK YOU CENTER
WORLD CENTER SKINNER HAS A
MOTION ON THE FLOOR CENTER
SKINNER'S ASKING FOR AN I.
VOTE. CENTER WILL CAUSE ASKING
FOR NO VOTE. I'M SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ALAN I
ARCHULETA I. ATKINS I BATES NO
BACKER. I PORCHES NO BRADFORD I
HAVE I GOTTA. CORTEZ THREE FIVE
DALLY. NO DOT. HI TORONTO HI
ADNAN I BELIEVE- I GONZALEZ I
GROVE NO HERZBERG FIVE WITH SO.
HI HER TADO I JONES NO
CAMCORDER I LAYERED HI LLEVA HI
RAMON. MCGUIRE HI MELINDA'S NO
MEN FIVE NEWMAN I NIELSEN NO A
SHOW OF BOTH. NO TAN I FOURTEEN
TINA I BROUGHT HI RUBIO I
SKINNER I STERN HI I'M BURKE I
LIKE HOW SKI FIVE WINNER I WILL.
NO. SIZE TWENTY NINE KNOWS NINE
MAJOR OUR MOTION PASSES ARE
REMAINING IN MOTIONS AND
RESOLUTIONS ANY OTHER MEMBERS
NEEDING TO BE RECOGNIZED FOR
MOTIONS AND RESOLUTIONS.
SENATOR ALAN. YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED AS THE PRESIDENT
LIKE TO ASK THAT WE AT THE AT
THE REQUEST OF THE AUTHOR THAT
WE- REMOVE AG ARE TOO THIS IS
HOWEVER- DONALDS BILL WE WANT
TO REMOVE IT FROM THE CONSENT
CALENDAR FOR THE PURPOSE OF
ADDING. CO AUTHORS- I WOULD
LIKE TO. HELLO FROM CONSENT FOR
CHAPTER IN AMENDMENTS. EIGHTY
SIX NINETY EIGHT- BYE BYE
SUMMER COURT JUSTICE TOO THANK
YOU THANK YOU SIR ALAN THE
OTHER MEMBERS ON- MOTIONS AND
RESOLUTIONS. THANK YOU WE CAN
COME BACK LATER IF NECESSARY
THE OTHER FIVE. CAN SINK
COUNTER NEEDS TO BE PULLED
WE'RE GONNA MOVE ON TO THE
CONSIDERATION OF THE DAILY FILE
MEMBERS. SECOND READING FILE
SECRETARY PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY
BILL FIVE NINETY TWO WITH
AMENDMENTS TWELVE TWENTY WITH
AMENDMENTS. THREE NINETY SIX
WITH AMENDMENTS FOR NINETY NINE
WITH AMENDMENTS TO TWENTY ONE
WITH AMENDMENTS EIGHT OH EIGHT
WITH AMENDMENTS AS ONLY ABOUT
THIRTEEN WITH THAT AND MAY BE
DEEMED RED THANK YOU MADAM
SECRETARY MOVING ONTO
GOVERNOR'S APPOINTMENTS CENTER
LAYERED YOU'RE RECOGNIZED IN
THE REAR OF THE CHAMBER. THANK
YOU MR PRESIDENT OF FILE ITEM
NUMBER TWENTY THREE IS THE
CONFIRMATION OF GERALD LOZANO.
AS ASSOCIATE DIRECTOR OF HIGH
SECURITY MENTAL INSTITUTIONS AT
THE DEPARTMENT OF CORRECTIONS
AND REHABILITATION HISPANICIZED
TIRE CAREER AT C. D. C. R.
SINCE STARTING AS A CORRECTION
OFFICER IN NINETEEN NINETY
SEVEN. HE WAS APPROVED BY THE
SENATE RULES COMMITTEE ON JUNE
NINTH ON A FIVE ZERO VOTE I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
RIVAL. THANK YOU SENATOR LARRY
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THE
SIDE OF MEMBERS ANY DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE. SEEING NONE
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALAN I ARCHULETA HI AT KINS I
BASE I BECKER. HI FOR JUST FIVE
BRADFORD I HAVE I GOTTA.
QUARTET V. I. DALLY I DONT I
THEY'RE AWESOME HI ADNAN HI
GLAZER FIVE DOLLARS HIGH GROWTH
I HEARD SPURRED BY WESTERN. I
HER TADO HI JONES I CAN LONGER
I LAYERED HI LLEVA FIVE THE MON.
MCGUIRE HI MELINDA'S. FIVE MEN
I NEWMAN I NELSON I WOULD SHOW
UP BOTH. I PAN I FORTUNE TINO.
HI ROTH I RUBIO I SKINNER I
STERN HI NUMBER FIVE WHITE
HOUSE E. FIVE WINNER I WILL. HI.
BY ADAM LIMONEIRA HI. HIGHS
THIRTY NINE KNOWS ZERO
APPOINTMENT IS CONFIRMED.
LADIES AND GENTLEMAN GONNA MOVE
ONTO ASSEMBLY THIRD READING WE
ARE FIRST GOING TO TAKE UP ITEM
FORTY NINE SECRETARY PLEASE
REACH. ASSEMBLY BILL TWO
SEVENTY ONE BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
ROBERT RIVAS AN ACT RELATING TO
PUBLIC CONTRACTS. CENTER LAYER
IS PRESENTING THE SILENCE IN
EARLIER THANK YOU VERY MUCH-
THIS BILL IS ABOUT ANDERSON DAM
WHICH IS ABOVE THE CITY OF
MORGAN HILL IN SANTA CLARA
COUNTY AND IS OPERATED BY THE
SANTA CLARA WATER DISTRICT THE
DAM IS UNDERGOING A MUCH NEEDED
SEISMIC RETROFIT. AND HAS
SUBSTANTIAL WATER DRAINED FROM
IT AND TELL THE REST. OF THE
RETROFIT IS DONE IT'S A BAD
SITUATION IN THE MIDDLE OF A
DROUGHT. THIS BILL AUTHORIZES
VALLEY WATER TO USE THE BEST
VALUE METHOD IN SELECTING THE
CONSTRUCTION OF A CONTRACTOR
FOR THE ANDERSON PROJECT. WHICH
WAS RECOMMENDED BY THE EXPERTS
CONVENED BY THE FEDERAL ENERGY
REGULATORY. COMMISSION INSTEAD
OF A MANDATED SELECTION OF THE
LOWEST BIDDER IT ALSO ENSURES
THAT A SKILLED AND TRAINED
WORKFORCE IS EMPLOYED FOR THIS
COMPLICATED AND- COMPLEX
PROJECT IT'S RECEIVED UNANIMOUS
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASKS FOR AN
ENVELOPE. THANK YOU SIR LET ANY
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THE
SIDE OF MEMBERS ANY DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE. I BELIEVE. THIS ITEM
IS QUALIFIES FOR UNANIMOUS ROLL
CALL IS THERE ANY OBJECTION TO
USING UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL ON
THIS ITEM. SEEING NO OBJECTION
HIGHS THIRTY NINE TO KNOW ZERO
MAJOR PASSES THANK YOU SIR
WHERE. MEMBERS WERE GOING TO
MOVE ON TO THE CONSENT CALENDAR
AND IF THE SECRETARY CAN PLEASE
READ. ASSEMBLY BILL. THREE OH
TWO FIVE NINETY ONE SEVEN
TWELVE ELEVEN EIGHTY ONE TWENTY
TWO FORTY SIX THREE OH SIX
THREE EIGHTY TWO THREE NINETY
EIGHT OR TWENTY NINE.
484-044-6650. 627-640-4740 TWO
EIGHT NINETEEN. 771-065-1290
ONE. ASSEMBLY BILL. FOURTEEN
TWENTY EIGHT FIFTEEN TWENTY
SEVEN FIFTEEN EIGHTY TWO
FIFTEEN EIGHTY THREE ASSEMBLY
CONCURRENT RESOLUTION FIFTY
THREE ASSEMBLY CONCURRENT
RESOLUTION SEVENTEEN FORTY ONE
EIGHTY FOUR ASSEMBLY BILL FOUR
SEVENTY SEVEN TO FIFTY ONE.
ASSEMBLY CONCURRENT RESOLUTION
TO THIRTY SIX SEVENTY AND
EIGHTY SIX. THANK YOU MA'AM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALLEN HI I. ARCHULETA I AT KINS
FIVE BATES I BECKER. HI PORCHES
HI BRADFORD I COME BY ADAM.
CORTESE HI DALLY. GOD I THERE
ARE SO. EGGMAN HI GLAZER HI
GONZALEZ HI GROWTH. HERTZBERG I
WAS SO. HI HER TADO HI JONES I
CAN'T LONGER I LAYERED I. LEIVA.
BY THE MON I REQUIRE. HI
MELINDA'S I MAN I NEWMAN I
NELSON I A TELEVOTE I CAN. FIVE
FORTUNE TINO HI RALPH HI RUBIO
I SKINNER I STERN HI I'M BURKE
I LIKE HOW SKI I WINNER I WILL
HI PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS. COME BY ADAM. DALLY I.
THERE ALSO I GROVE HI. HACE
THIRTY NINE NO ZERO CONSENT
COUNTER PASSES. SENATORS WERE
GONNA MOVE ON TO SPECIAL
CONSENT CALENDAR IF THE
SECRETARY CAN PLEASE READ. I'M
SORRY. WE ALREADY DID THAT SEE
HOW EFFICIENT WE ARE THIS
MORNING. MEMBERS ARE GONNA MOVE
ON THE COMMITTEE ANNOUNCEMENTS
WE HAVE A COUPLE OF COMMITTEE
NOW SINCE THIS MORNING SENATOR
RUBIO I THINK YOU HAVE AN
ANNOUNCEMENT. YES THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR AT INSURANCE
COMMITTEE WILL CONVENE AFTER
SESSION THANK YOU IN HERE IN
THE CHAMBER. THANK YOU SENATOR
RUBIO CENTER MCGUIRE. WHEN WE
WANT TO SENATOR GONZALES. A
SENATE TRANSPORTATION WILL MEET
IN CHAMBERS AT UPON THE
ADJOURNMENT OF SENATE INSURANCE
COMMITTEE THANK YOU. SOON
REQUIRE YOUR RECOGNIZED. FROM
SINNERS PROCESSING THANK YOU SO
MUCH MISTER CHAIR MISTER
PRESIDENT- GOVERNANCE AND
FINANCE WILL BE MEETING IN ROOM
FORTY TWO OH THREE AT TEN TEN
ROOM FORTY TWO- THREE TEN TEN
GOVERNANCE AND FINANCE THANK
YOU SIR REQUIRE- TO REPEAT THE
SENATOR RUBIO IS INSURANCE IN
THE- CHAMBERS SOON ACQUIRES
GOVERNOR AND FINANCE IN FORTY
TWO OR THREE AND CENTER
GONZALES'S TRANSPORTATION IN
UPON ADOURNMENT OF INSURANCE
IN THE CHAMBER'S. MEMBERS WE'RE
GONNA REMOVE RETURNED TO THE
MOTIONS AND RESOLUTIONS BEFORE
WE TAKE UP AND GERMANS AND
MEMORIES ARE THERE ANY MEMBERS
THAT NEED TO BE RECOGNIZED IN
MOTIONS AND RESOLUTIONS. YES
SENATOR MELINDA IS FOR WHAT
PURPOSE DO YOU RISE. THANK YOU
MR PRESIDENT. I PURSUANT TO
SENATE RULE TWENTY EIGHT I'M
MAKING A MOTION TO WITHDRAW S.
C. R. FIVE FROM THE SENATE
GOVERNMENTAL ORGANIZATION
COMMITTEE BROUGHT TO THE SENATE
FLOOR SO THAT WE MAY HAVE A
FULL AND RIGOROUS DEBATE OVER
THE CONTINUED MERITS OF THE
GOVERNOR'S STATE OF EMERGENCY.
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN HAS BEEN
FOUR HUNDRED AND SIXTY EIGHT
DAYS SINCE THE GOVERNOR
DECLARED A STATE OF EMERGENCY
FOR KEVIN AND SHUTS DOWN. IF
THE CORONER MELINDA'S I AM-
BEING INFORMED THAT YOUR MOTION
IS OUT OF ORDER BECAUSE WE DO
NOT HAVE A LETTER AT THE DESK.
AND WE WILL TAKE JUST A MINUTE
TO DOUBLE CHECK THAT PLEASE.
CENTERS WE'RE GONNA MOVE TO
GERMAN MEMORIES WHILE WE CLEAN
UP THAT ISSUE IF WE CAN- HAVE
SENATOR WAY SO. WE HAVE THREE
GERMAN MEMORIES THIS MORNING-
SINNERS IF WE CAN- BE READY FOR
THOSE THAT MEMBERS ARE
PRESENTING THOSE. SENATOR WAY
SO. THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT
SENATORS- TODAY I RISE TO
ADJOURN IN MEMORY. ON BEHALF OF
NINA ALLEVIATE A KAPOOR A
STRONG LEGISLATIVE ADVOCATE A
DEVOTED DAUGHTER A WIFE. A
MOTHER AND A FRIEND A FRIEND TO
MANY OF US HERE. IN THE SENATE
IN THE LEGISLATURE. FORMER US
SENATE EMPLOYEE. NINA RECEIVED
HER BACHELOR'S DEGREE IN
POLITICAL SCIENCE AND ECONOMICS
FROM THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA SAN DIEGO. SHE WAS A
SENATE FELLOW IN THE OFFICE OF
FORMER STATE SENATOR JOS MIDIAN
DURING THE 200-062-0007
SESSION. AFTER HER FELLOWSHIP
MEN NEED TO WORK IN THE OFFICE
OF FORMER ASSEMBLY MEMBER.
FELIPE IF WINTERS ON ENERGY
POLICY ISSUES IN EARLY TWENTY
TEN. SHE CONTINUED HER WORK IN
CALIFORNIA STATE GOVERNMENT AS
BOTH THE CONTRACT AND IN HOUSE
LOBBYIST. MOST RECENTLY SHE
WORK FOR THE COALITION OF
RENEWABLE NATURAL GAS AND THE
DIRECTOR OF STATE GOVERNMENTAL
AFFAIRS. SHE HAD A GREAT CAREER
THAT BREAK BEGAN RIGHT HERE IN
THE SENATE AS A FELLOW. AND I
MINNIE SCHMIT VERY SURE THAT
MANY OF YOU HAD THE DISTINCT
PLEASURE OF WORKING WITH HER. I
WORKED WITH HER ON THE BILL-
TWO YEARS AGO AND- I HAD THE
CHANCE TO WORK WITH HER WHEN I
WAS IN THE ASSEMBLY ON A BILL
THAT MANY PEOPLE THOUGHT
THOUGHT WAS IMPOSSIBLE TO PASS-
WHERE SHE COALESCED- BOTH. THE
RIGHT AND LEFT BEHIND A PRETTY
BIG POLICY. OF ONE WHO SHE WAS
REPRESENTING THE LUMBER
INDUSTRY AND IT WAS A- BIG
VICTORY FOR. NOT ONLY THE
LUMBER INDUSTRY BUT THE WHOLE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA'S
LEGISLATURE. WHEN SHE WAS NOT
WORKING SHE WAS ENJOYING
COOKING TAKING TRIPS TO
DISNEYLAND HIKING AND SPENDING
TIME WITH HER FAMILY. SHE WILL
NEVER A SHE WILL. SHE WILL
FOREVER BE REMEMBERED AS AN
EMPOWERED INTELLIGENT CREATIVE
AND SPIRITUAL WOMAN SHE WILL BE
GREATLY MISSED SHE IS SURVIVED
BY HER HUSBAND JASON HER SON
SAWYER HER MOTHER SUNITA HER
BROTHER ROBBIE FAMILY FRIENDS
AND COLLEAGUES. A FUNERAL
SERVICE WILL BE HELD THIS
SATURDAY FOLLOWING A VIEWING. I
ASK YOU TO JOIN ME TODAY IN THE
JOURNEY IN MEMORY. OF NINA.
LEVATOR COURSE THANK YOU. THANK
YOU SAMMY SOSA REDFORD ON THIS.
YES THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT I TO
RISE AND NOT AS THAT WE ADJOURN
IN MEMORY OF OUR REMARKABLE
INDIVIDUAL WHO. I HAD THE
PLEASURE WORKING WENT ON A
VARIETY OF ISSUES- NOT ONLY AS
A LOBBYIST OR WHEN SHE WAS
EMPLOYED HERE AS WELL. AND AS
ARE MY COLLEAGUE FROM SAN DIEGO
STATED SHE USES AMAZING
CREATIVE INDIVIDUAL BUT- WHAT
MANY MIGHT NOT KNOW SHE WAS
INCREDIBLE DJ. AND HER PASSION
FOR MUSIC IS WHAT REALLY-
BONDED US TOGETHER AND DURING
THE SOCIAL CAUCUSES THAT WE
HAVE BEEN EXPERIENCING A LOT
YOUR NAV. SHE WAS MANY TIMES
THE DJ AT MANY OF THESE EVENTS
MIXING MUSIC INCREDIBLY SO SHE
WILL BE SORELY MISSED SHE WAS
VERY A GREAT. FORCE TO BRING
ALL PARTIES TOGETHER BOTH SIDES
OF THE AISLE ALL INDUSTRIES
TOGETHER THROUGH. THE SOCIAL
ASPECT THAT SOMETIMES IS NOT
APPRECIATED ANYMORE AND- THIS
BUSINESS AND IN THIS BUILDING
SO I TO ASK. THAT WE ADJOURN IN
MEMORY OF NICKEL POOR. THANK
YOU SIR BRADFORD ST ADMIN ON
THIS ITEM. CENTERING IN THE
CORNER. THANK YOU VERY MUCH MR
PRESIDENT MEMBERS I'D ALSO LIKE
TO RISE IN THE IN MEMORY OF
MUNICH POOR- AND THEN JUST TO
MAKE THE POINT AS AS A WOMAN AS
A WOMAN OF COLOR- HER USE HER
ENERGY I THINK REALLY- CALL TO
MANY OF US MANY OF US I THINK
COULD SEE OURSELVES IN HER.
WITH HER HER ENERGY AND AGAIN
HER HER LOVE OF LIFE HER LOVE
OF MUSIC HER LOVE OF PEOPLE-
AND AS WE ALL KNOW THIS
BUSINESS CAN IS NOT ALWAYS
EASY- AND FOR A YOUNG WOMAN OF
COLOR I THINK TO DO. TO BE ABLE
TO DO THE THINGS THAT SHE DID
WAS WAS REMARKABLE I THINK SHE
LEFT AN IMPRESSION ON HIS
BUILDING AND MAY HER MEMORY
CONTINUE TO BE A BLESSING TO
ALL OF US AND TO CONTINUE TO
REMEMBER. TO TURN TO EACH OTHER.
DURING NOT DURING JUST GOOD
TIMES BUT DURING BAD TIMES AS
WELL AND THAT THE THAT THIS
BUSINESS- ASKS US TO BE HUMAN
WHEN SOMETIMES- THE FORCES ASK
US NOT TO BE SO BUT IT'S JUST
IN HER MEMORY CONTINUE TO BE
KIND TO CONTINUE TO CELEBRATE
LIFE. AND CONTINUE TO HONOR
THIS WORK WE DO- IN HER MEMORY.
THANK YOU SIR EDMUND SENATOR
DELHI. THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS ALSO LIKE TO RISE- GOT
TO KNOW NINA WHEN SHE WAS
WORKING FOR THE FORESTRY
ASSOCIATION MANY VIEW THAT WENT
ON OUR TOURS REMEMBER THAT
NEEDED JOIN US ON THOSE TOURS
AND I JUST WANNA SAY WHAT AN-
AWESOME PERSON SHE- THAT. WAS
IN THE IN THE FIND THAT SHE HAD
AT THE COURT OF CORDIAL CAUCUS
I REMEMBER THOSE. TIMES WE
WOULD GO TO SIMON'S AND- DO
KARAOKE- SO I JUST WANT TO
SHARE THAT- WILL SHE'S USUALLY
MASTIN MY CONDOLENCES GO OUT TO
HER FAMILY. THANK YOU SIR DELL
ANY OTHER MEMBERS ON THIS ITEM.
WILL MOVE ON TO THE NEXT
ADJOURNMENT MEMORY CENTER- BERG.
YOU'RE RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU MR
PRESIDENT MEMBERS I RISE TO
REMARK ON THE LIFE OF IN HONOR
OF THE- REVEREND FATHER TROND
KONG NI REVEREND JOHN CONNIE
WAS BORN MARCH THIRTEENTH
NINETEEN FORTY FIVE AND FIVE
DM. DIOCESE OF NINH BINH.
BITNAMI INTENDED CATHOLIC
CEMETERY IN VIETNAM BEFORE
MOVING TO ROME FOR STUDIES AT
THE PONTIFICAL URBAN UNIVERSITY
EVENTUALLY BECOMING A PRIEST IN
NINETEEN SEVENTY ONE NINETEEN
SEVENTY EIGHT HE RECEIVED HS
DOCTOR OF PHILOSOPHY DEGREE IN
THEOLOGY FROM THE PONTIFICAL
URBAN AND ST GREGORY'S
UNIVERSITIES AND WRONG. DURING
HIS MINISTRY FATHER AND HE
SERVED AS A CHAPLAIN FOR THE
FORT CHAFFEE REFUGEE CAMP WE
WELCOME VIETNAMESE REFUGEES THE
UNITED STATES AFTER THE- FALL
OF SOUTH VIETNAM. HE ALSO
SERVED PARISHES AND DIOCESES
ALL OVER THE UNITED STATES
INCLUDING ACTING AS THE
DIRECTOR OF RESEARCH FOR THE
VIETNAMESE PASTORAL NEEDS IN
THE UNITED STATES PROJECT- FOR
UNITED STATES PROJECT IN ORANGE
COUNTY. WITH THE ADVENT OF NEW
TECHNOLOGY IN THE LATE NINETEEN
EIGHTIES AND EARLY NINETY NINE
NINETIES PHONY. DEVOTED HIS
SPARE TIME. DEVELOPING AN
ONLINE FAITH BASED COMMUNITY
AND FOUNDED VIET CATHOLIC. THAT
NETWORK SERVE MILLIONS OF
VIETNAMESE PEOPLE AROUND THE
WORLD WITH INFORMATION ON
CURRENT EVENTS COMMENTARIES AND
SPIRITUAL REFLECTION FOLLOW ME
WILL BE REMEMBERED FOR HIS
DEDICATED SERVICE TO HIS
COMMUNITY HIS FAITH IS LIMITED
LIMITLESS INNOVATION IS NEVER
ENDING CAPACITY TO EXCEL. THANK
YOU COLLEAGUES IN ADJOURNING IN
HIS MEMORY. THANK YOU SIR
NUMBER NEXT AS SENATOR WIENER
CINNAMON. THANK YOU MR
PRESIDENT COLLEAGUES I RISE
WITH GREAT SADNESS TODAY TO
ANNOUNCE THAT THE SENATE
ADJOURNED IN MEMORY OF TONY
RODRIGUEZ- TONY WAS BORN IN
NINETEEN FIFTY ONE- HE GREW UP
AND LATER RAISED HIS OWN FAMILY
AND THE GREAT CITY OF SAN
FRANCISCO- HE DEVOTED HIS
ENTIRE LIFE TO ADVOCATING FOR
OTHERS ARE PARTICULARLY FOR
WORKING PEOPLE. AND
VOLUNTEERING IN OUR COMMUNITY
TONY WAS INSPIRED BY HIS
PARENTS WHO WERE UNION MEMBERS
THEMSELVES TO GET INVOLVED IN
LABOR UNIONS ADVOCACY HAVING
SEEN FIRST HAND THE BENEFITS-
UNION JOBS PROVIDE ATTORNEY
DEVOTED HIS TIME AND MOST F
HIS LIFE TO ENSURING THOSE
PROTECTIONS FOR OTHERS. I
TWENTY BELIEVE THAT IN ORDER TO
AFFECT POSITIVE PROGRESS YOU
HAVE TO BE INVOLVED FROM
WITHIN. AS A RESULT OF TWENTY
HELD MULTIPLE LEADERSHIP ROLES-
IN THE NATIONAL AUTUMN
AUTOMATIC SPRINKLER FITTERS
UNION LOCAL FORTY THREE THE
SPRINKLER FITTERS- I WAS ALSO
DEEPLY INVOLVED IN THE SAN
FRANCISCO LABOR COUNCIL. HI
THIS IS UNION WORK TONY WAS
PROBABLY- AN APPOINTEE OF MAYOR
LONDON BREED TO THE SAN
FRANCISCO FIRE COMMISSION
SERVING AS A FIRE COMMISSIONER
I WAS ALSO AN ELECTED MEMBER OF
THE CALIFORNIA DEMOCRATIC
PARTY- ASSEMBLY- DELEGATE
CAUCUS. IS PERSONAL LIFE TONY
WAS A LOVING HUSBAND FATHER AND
UNCLE WHO NEVER PASSED UP AN
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEND TIME WITH
FAMILY. HE PASSED AWAY ON JUNE
SEVENTEENTH AT THE AGE OF SIXTY
NINE HE HAS SURVIVED BY HIS
WIFE AND FOUR CHILDREN- I ALSO
JUST SAY PERSONALLY TONY WAS
ONE OF THOSE PEOPLE I'VE KNOWN
HIM FOR A VERY VERY LONG TIME
THROUGH- THE LABOR MOVEMENT AND
THROUGH TESTING YOU WORK IN SAN
FRANCISCO. AND HE WAS ALL JUST
ALWAYS ONE OF THE KINDEST- MOST
SOFT SPOKEN UNDERSTATED-
PEOPLE'S HAS ALWAYS HAD A. KIND
WORD- JUST A REALLY ONE
THEREFORE ONE OF HUMAN BEING-
AND A LOT OF WERE WERE JUST
FLOW AND AS DEVON. TO HEAR OF
HIS PASSING SO TONY REST IN
PEACE. THANK YOU SERIN NERVE
REMAINING IN MOTIONS AND
RESOLUTIONS SENATOR MELINDA AS-
WHAT PURPOSE DO YOU RISE. THANK
YOU MR PRESIDENT AND I LIKE TO
OFFER MY CONDOLENCES TO MEMBERS
WHO HAVE- OFFERED UP DURING
MEMORIES OF THEIR CONSTITUENTS
TODAY AND I RISE PURSUANT TO
SENATE RULE TWENTY EIGHT TO
MAKE A MOTION TO WITHDRAW I SEE
R. FIVE IN THE SENATE
GOVERNMENTAL ORGANIZATION
COMMITTEE. AND BROUGHT TO THE
SENATE FLOOR. IT HAS BEEN FOUR
HUNDRED SIXTY EIGHT DAYS SINCE
THE GOVERNOR DECLARED A STATE
OF EMERGENCY AND SHUT DOWN THE
STATE. AND IF THE CRISIS IS
INDEED OVER WHICH HAS BEEN
INDICATED BY THE JUNE FIFTEENTH
RE OPENING DATE THEN THERE IS
NO LONGER A NEED. FOR THE STATE
OF EMERGENCY AND FOR THE
GOVERNOR'S UNILATERAL AT THE
READY. THE GOVERNOR AS YOU'RE
WELL AWARE IS NOW GIVING AWAY
CASH PRIZES LOTTERY TICKETS AND
GIFT CARDS TO THE TUNE OF ONE
AND A HALF MILLION DOLLARS TO
BRIBE. CALIFORNIANS INTO
GETTING VACCINES AND DEFLECT
ATTENTION AWAY FROM THE LAST
FOUR HUNDRED AND SIXTY FIVE
DAYS. ON JUNE SEVENTEENTH CAL
OSHA PROPOSED REVISIONS. TO THE
KEVIN NINETEEN EMERGENCY
TEMPORARY STANDARDS AND THE
GOVERNOR SIGNED AN EXECUTIVE
ORDER FOR IMMEDIATE EFFECT. IT
IMPORTANTLY STATED EMPLOYERS
MAY ALLOW FULLY VACCINATED
EMPLOYEES NOT TO WEAR FACE
COVERINGS INDOORS. SO WHY ARE
WE STILL IN A STATE OF
EMERGENCY. OUR UNEMPLOYMENT
RATE REMAINS ROUGHLY FOUR
PERCENTAGE POINTS HIGHER. THAN
BEFORE THE CRISIS IN IS HIGHER
THAN THE NATIONAL AVERAGE. ON
TOP OF THAT THE GOVERNOR IS
PREPARING TO ISSUE A SECOND
ROUND OF STATEWIDE RECALL
REFINANCE DIMINISHED CHECKS.
WHEN WE SHOULD BE FOCUSED ON
GETTING PEOPLE BACK TO WORK.
OVER THE WEEKEND MORE STATES
ENDED PANDEMIC RELATED
UNEMPLOYMENT BENEFITS BRINGING
THE TOTAL TO TWELVE SENATORS IT
HAS BEEN FOUR HUNDRED AND SIXTY
EIGHT DAYS. IT IS TIME WE IN
THE STATE OF EMERGENCY I ASK
FOR YOUR I. BOATS. THE
MELINDA'S HAS A MOTION ON THE
FLOOR SENATOR HERTZBERG. OPERA
PURPOSE YOUR RIGHTS AS MAJORITY
LEADER US FOR A NO VOTE. THANK
YOU THE CENTER'S BERG SENATOR
MELINDA IS ASKING FOR AN I.
VOTE SENATOR HERTZBERG IS
ASKING FOR A NO VOTE. SECRETARY
PLEASE RE READ- PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. ALAN NO ARCHULETA NO
ATKINS. BAYTEX I BACKER NO
PORCHES HI BRADFORD. NO COME BY
OTHER. CORTEZ HE. HI DALLY.
FIVE DOT. NO THEY'RE AWESOME NO
EGGMAN NO GLAZER. NO GONZALEZ
NO GROWTH. FIVE HERTZBERG NO
WAY SO. NO HER TADO NO JONES I
CAN LONGER NOTE LAYERED. NO
LLEVA NO AMOUNT NO MCGUIRE. NO
MELINDA'S I MEN. NO NEWMAN NO
NIELSEN I A SHOW OF BOTH. I CAN
NO FORTUNE TINO NO ROCK. NO
RUBIO. NO SKINNER NO STERN NO
AMBERG. NO WHITE HOUSE SKI NO
WINNER. NO WILKE. I. CORTESE I
DON'T KNOW. HIGHS NINE NOS
TWENTY NINE MOTION FAILS.
MOVING OUT OF REACH- MOTIONS
AND RESOLUTIONS MEMBERS OF
THERE IS NO OTHER BUSINESS
BEFORE THE FLOOR SENATOR BATES
THE DESK IS CLEAR. THANK YOU OF
THE SENATE WILL BE IN RECESS
UNTIL THREE THIRTY PM AT WHICH
TIME THE ADJOURNMENT MOTION
WILL BE PLACED WE WILL CONVENE
AT MONDAY AT TWO PM. THANK YOU
THANK YOU SENATOR BATES- I WAS
ASKED TO REMIND MEMBERS OF
INSURANCE INSURANCE WILL START
AROUND TEN O'CLOCK. THE SENATE
WILL BE IN RECESS UNTIL THREE
THIRTY PM AT WHICH TIME THE
GERMAN MOTION WILL BE PLACED
AND WE WILL RECONVENE ON
MONDAY. AT TWO PM MONDAY TWO PM
THANK YOU LADIES AND GENTLEMEN.